[Music]
I had one kid say you're famous and I
said oh I'm not at all famous compared
to Michael Jackson the kid said not that
kind of famous art famous mofo that kind
of fascinating
I'm William Wegman and most people know
me as the dog photographer
[Music]
I've been working with Weimar owners for
over 45 years if I had a better voice I
compose a song about all the dogs I've
had first there was man ray and then
came Fay Wray but I won't burden you
with that now I have two dogs Flo and
her brother topper and they're really
hello Flo they're pretty amazing
together
in my photographs what I like people to
see is that yes there's a dog and yes
it's a Weimaraner but what has it become
the dogs are always in a state of
becoming something they become
characters objects when they're lying
down there they're becoming landscapes
they let you do it it's something
special it's something unique it happens
only when we go to the studio and
there's an arena established for this
activity I live in Chelsea area of New
York I have this really great studio and
tons of props stored in the basement I'm
gonna need to go down and get those
vests ball gowns and ugly stepsister
outfits doodads and crazy hats and wigs
and all kinds of things I'm seeing
something on the floor Hawk gotta use
that put that on the dog's head
some people are alarmed when they see
human hands attached to the arms I like
that because it's almost like mythology
you know an Egyptian god with a bird
head and human hands well we really only
need that so I'll just try that I really
need that energy of the lights the
camera the focus good girl
[Music]
my work sort of jumped out of the art
world into everybody's world I've seen
my work appear on the whole array of
things children's books videos for
Sesame Street films all kinds of things
it was a time when I just felt like I
was nailed to the dog cross I wanted to
to escape that now I'm kind of
comfortable with that and I feel really
lucky to to have this I think these
might be my last two dogs I'm in my 70s
and I'll be in my 80s when they're gone
do I really want to burn my family with
other dogs I don't know it's up to them
when I'm 95 and they want another dog
okay I'll get one
[Music]
you